somebody who can now laugh about the
double punt
because it didn't it didn't break the
rams last night that's one of those
moments where just like we block a punt
and then they get 62 net yards off of it
like how does that happen
but there was so much adversity for this
los angeles rams team on thursday night
football and they overcame it with a big
w
and one of the best of the best at his
position in not just his position but
humans in the national football league
veteran of this league and of course los
angeles he is none other than andrew
whitworth offensive lineman how are you
sir
i'm doing great rich i appreciate you
having me on that that was quite an
episode there the double punt first time
i've seen that right i mean
i've never seen anything like that
before
what what what was your reaction what
was the sideline reaction to that when
that happened
i think the best part of it was looking
at every coach and every player you know
you're trying to have poise in the
moment rich and i don't think one single
guy knew what the answer was is that
illegal is that legal
nobody knows what's going on the rest
don't look like they have any idea
what's going on
it's uh it was pretty funny just
watching everybody's face of who was
giving the first one to say what the
rule was
and so at what one ended up happening i
mean because i was i was looking at the
the description given to to mcveigh and
you know bless sean i mean he is as you
know uh he's he's i wouldn't say even
keel because he's got a keel to him but
um you know but it is even whatever his
keel is it just happens to be higher
than most people's even um he he just
took it in stride like okay i guess
you're pinned back instead of getting
the the ball
deep in the other team's zone like that
you you're on the plus side of the field
is the day is long ready to put that
thing in in the freezer after yeah you
know it's one of those things i think uh
it was an if you say so moment you know
it's like uh
you know none of us really know what the
rule was in the moment i mean it's never
really come up you know that you can
think of and it's like well they're
saying and you know this is what the
rule is and he didn't cross the line of
scrimmage and
you know and and they kind of told sean
basically from what they were looking at
the people helping them that they didn't
think he was past the line of scrimmage
and obviously it was something we could
have possibly challenged but in the
moment you're just like okay if that's
what the rule is then sure but it
doesn't look like anybody really knows
whether that's accurate or not what's
hacker jealous though deep down do you
think he's jealous oh there's no
question i mean
it's just one of those nights for you if
you block a punt end up with a net
62-yard plant oh my goodness but i mean
he's got everything in his bag as we
know i mean including a a nice uh spiral
he's got to be like i didn't know you
could double punt i got to put that in
my arsenal you know yeah johnny hecker
right now sitting at home thinking how
can he work that into his game it might
be the only thing he hasn't done as a
punter yet
double punt man and andrew whitworth of
the rams here on the rich eisen show day
after the rams
um survive and also win uh a game um in
seattle i guess there's two ways to put
it um walk me through what you found out
about were you there when stafford put
his finger back in to place i mean what
was that
kind of grab his finger after one of the
series and i was like man you know i
worried about it obviously because he's
you know he had the thumb surge in the
offseason so i don't know what it was
and then
you know sure enough
get on the sideline he's like yeah man i
think it was just out a little bit and i
just you know popped it back in
and uh you know
just that's who he is though i mean that
guy man you think of his career the
injuries he's had the things he's
overcome and games i mean he's a tough
dude man and i'll tell you what one guy
we're really happy to have yeah i know i
mean and when you describe him being a
tough dude and you you're going in the
past because obviously your present is
not
too deep because of uh his arrival just
this past uh winter but
nobody's tighter than a quarterback in
their line and certainly somebody like
you who protects
him um what is your relationship what
have you learned about matthew stafford
andrew whitworth you know just mainly
that i mean just as simple as that
moment was that he just you know he
handled something his fingers hurt but
he you know he just goes gets taped up
gets it fixed and gets rolling and
really doesn't say a word about it to
anybody i mean he's just that you know
as
guys put it it's you he's just a guy man
he's he's tough he's he's a hard worker
he's really really intelligent and he's
just somebody that people gravitate to
immediately when you're around and just
because of really how he carries himself
and the way he goes about his business i
think guys just gravitate to his energy
and and even in the huddle i mean he's
just so relaxed and competent
but that stuff just you know it's
infectious and and i think guys feel
more comfortable and they feel more
confident when they're around him and
in this little time we've been together
man it's it's just it sticks out why so
many guys across the league have so much
respect for him and and why why those
players in detroit love him so much and
uh have always endeared to him so much
do you ever think you'd say that about a
georgia bulldog andrew
you know rich it hurts to even make that
comment you know it started with todd
gurley and then right now it's him and
it's just that's right it's really
hurting me right now these georgia
bulldogs that i keep liking i mean you
know i'm not supposed to like any of
them i understand that you're an lsu man
i totally get it but uh just three
points in the first half that's only
happened before last night four times uh
since sean mcvay took the reins as the
hc of the lar so what was it like in the
locker room last night down 7-3 andrew
real one of those things if you look at
it like stat wise just moving the
football that we felt like we were doing
that and just and then just not
converting and not finding a way to get
that one more first down would really
get us rolling um and and i think that's
one of those things we felt like man we
have just left so many plays out there
all always in the halftime really always
in there like no one was like upset or
anything it was literally like hey guys
just execute and we'll be fine like
that's all we have to do like that's all
we have to do do your job and we'll be
fine because it's out there you know
what we had planned to do is there
sure enough you saw that in the second
half really nothing changed other than
just we started executing the plays they
were called and uh to the level that we
expect and you know i think we felt like
leaving that game that we really left a
lot of points out there and
one of those things a great second half
but first half has to be better and you
know it's funny andrew andrew whitworth
here on the rich eisen show the number
of times that i you know when we have
mariucci um we ask him for his analysis
or
um any time that you hear somebody like
yourself say all we have to do is just
execute do what we do but just do it
better and execute better and it
frustrates fans because they were like
well how how does it happen in the first
place or or how can the team just get
better how can a team get better and so
on and so forth when it's just as we
know what we need to do and we just need
to do it better and there's a certain
confidence level that comes with that
because you know your coach and
everybody else has put you in the right
position and i'm wondering
how that feels as a veteran football
player
andrew what's fantastic i mean when you
know you're in the right spots i think
it's one of those things that sometimes
fans might not see the production that
they want
but you kind of feel like hey you know
what like we're right there like this is
actually a great plan we actually feel
like we're in a great spot we just
haven't quite hit it i always relate it
to like a shooter you know like these
three point shooters in basketball in
the nba like they might come out the
beginning of the game and miss a couple
and then you'll see them like stay with
it and then it's like you know because
they feel good about it they're just a
little off and then once they find that
groove it's lights out and that's how we
kind of felt last night is like
we were just just a tick off on a couple
of little execution things and if we
just stuck with it the plays are there
we can get hot and we felt like that's
what happened eventually we finally hit
a couple plays in a row and then it was
like all right we're hot we're ready we
want the football we want the
opportunity to go get back on the field
every chance we get yeah nothing's worse
than sitting on a loss for an entire
week and certainly before bye week and
whatever you had a short week so
obviously that that that taste of what
happened against arizona is out of your
mouth but i'm a member of the media so
it's my job to put it back in there what
happened
what happened against arizona and based
on and what you could dissect and and
understand and take with you
uh to avoid it as a team andrew well you
really look at it i mean how clean we
played offensively going up into that
game and having some penalties uh
turning the ball over twice in the first
half
you give a chance like arizona it's a
great offensive football team
really to get themselves a lead and put
themselves in a position where they can
kind of dictate the terms a little bit
and do a little bit of everything they
want to do and so you know for us
offensively we just didn't execute in
the first half and turn the ball over
and you just can't do that and and i
think we
you know feel like that's one of those
games where uh we look forward to that
next opportunity because we feel like we
really uh kind of handed the first half
to those guys and got ourselves so
behind that uh in the nfl it's hard when
you get down in the second half
uh teams do a great job possess the
football and and that's what they really
did to us and you know i think for us uh
it's just building and realizing hey man
it's not always the best team it's the
best team in those three hour windows
and we got to do whatever it takes to be
at our best every single sunday during
that three hour window and that's one of
those that we just weren't
andrew whitworth here on the rich eisen
show after a week five thursday night uh
kickoff win uh against the seattle
seahawks from the los angeles rams right
here on the rich eisen show year 16
brother i mean right you're you're 17
right you've had 16 years in is this
year 17 or 16. you're 16. you're 16.
okay so um
how are you i mean like how how
like and and and and how do you think
this season can wind up here i mean this
is this is a window for you you know
brady's not the only 40 year old that
was on that field a couple of weeks ago
uh in so far how about you andrew yeah
man you know what it's it's uh probably
some of the most fun i've ever had man i
just enjoying the game and
enjoying really our group and having
been here now uh five years to really
kind of be in the building and formed a
lot of great relationships and also some
of these young linemen i'm getting to
play with that have really kind of come
into their own this year and are really
playing well um you know it's just a
it's a fun moment i get to be kind of a
big brother dad slash you know a player
uh teammate i mean it's just it's like
proud that some of the guys and the way
they're playing and watching some of
these young pups come up since i got
here to
also just getting to go out there and
and go get after it with them and so
i've been having a blast man it's so
much fun and uh i love our team i love
our buildings and uh i look forward to
hopefully having a great season you know
what we we uh we want to bring something
special to los angeles so that's the
goal in mind one of those pups is that
is that
how you refer to aaron donald too andrew
or no you know uh cause that's a grown
ass man right i mean that guy's a pup
that's a bad man right i'm saying what
is it like in practice
with him
it's annoying it's uh it's it's one of
those things that uh every day he just
wrecks your day in training camp uh
where you feel like you have a lot of
great plays lined up and just uh aaron
donald
never ceases to just destroy the whole
entire game plan of the day and
and uh it's just it's it's uh not a lot
of fun facing that guy day in and day
out i really appreciate when training
camp's over rich i bet but uh does it
does that translate into a game when
you're facing somebody who's whose job
it is to wreck your day and
you've already been through that
throughout the week in training no
question i mean a.d is one of those guys
that there's not many moves and hand
techniques and and really
just uh everything he uses body wise to
beat guys i mean he has the whole
arsenal so you'll play guys throughout
the season that you may say hey he tries
to do this similar to a.d or this is a
similar move but he doesn't quite
execute it the way ad does and and just
really uh he's a guy i know for our
guards inside especially
um the hand games he plays and how good
he is getting off the blocks i mean it's
it's uh i wouldn't say it's easy but man
does it make those guys pretty
comfortable sitting in there on sundays
facing guys that they know
uh just not the genetic freaks that
aaron donald is and uh it definitely
makes us all better that's for sure i
mean i think that he is the epitome of
iron sharpens iron i mean that dude if
you can block him uh you get immediate
feedback on how good you're playing ah i
love that
before i let you go how's your community
works what's going on with you off the
field what are you doing man
everything's good you know we started
something this year uh every home game
i'm donating some money um you know
really to try and have an opportunity to
be a part of the homeless situation in
l.a and we uh
you know are trying to do things for
being able to give grants to people to
have their first home and and then also
we're also taking some of that money and
going to louisiana and trying to do some
uh
repairs and get people back in their
houses and apartments and everything
else in new orleans with after the
hurricane so i'm doing our best man to
just always try to be a part of uh being
there for people and taking the platform
we have make a difference man it's the
greatest opportunity we have
and uh i just look forward to always
trying to do that and man just look up
to guys like you who do the same thing
man who always set the tone
please come on i appreciate you saying
that but how can we how can we be a part
how can people lend assistance or is
there anything that we could do or yeah
and uh you know what we're we're gonna
do this kind of all year and and uh
we uh you know what just email us at the
rams and want to be a part of it okay
and uh we're gonna continue to fundraise
all we can and try to make any
difference we can you're the man hey
before i let you go uh because you know
i'm i'm a lead pipe wielding uh
professional journalistically and i
gotta button everything up uh andrew
whitworth did they uh did your coach go
back on the team playing with you last
night
oh man he did he actually made it back
on the team playing uh you know
you know it's shockingly enough uh
between sean mcvay and marvin lewis i've
never had a coach not come back on the
team playing with me on a thursday well
i'm just asking because you know last
thursday um the team that played on the
road there was something up i don't know
if you heard something happened oh yeah
no i hadn't heard about it i have to
look it up okay so uh oh so sean was on
the plane right so
okay so everything's good with the rams
very good yeah just good man we ride
together i just wanted to check that box
you know because that's because that's
what i do i just need to i just need to
journalistically uh make sure that all
boxes need checks thank you sir take
care of yourself andrew whitworth i
really appreciate it i know that you're
operating on zero sleep um so i
appreciate you calling in thanks hey
thank you so much man you have a great
weekend okay right back at you that's
andrew whitworth
16-year nfl veteran and los angeles rams
pass and run protector right here on the
rich isaac big man
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here